what's the most iconic Bruce Lee moved
one inch punch for sure one inch punch
so one inch punch Bruce did this in 1964
at the Long Beach International karate
tournaments and it's a technique tissue
not a fighting technique but the
technique to show that you can generate
power with speed and technique if you're
only one inch away correct as opposed to
having big mouths or having to wind up
right so I'm gonna do this on you but I
have to warn you that it can cause
internal damage it could cause your
heart to explode cracked sternum so I
have this then why do it at all well I
have this bat for you
this is gonna protect me it'll I'm not
gonna go full power okay okay
this is like a foam Ritz cracker all
right this is just to give you an idea
so very slowly from here one-inch pipe
and then I torque in like that okay so
not a big you didn't really do it really
do it well let me take this off okay
show this wait no no okay okay
I didn't yeah but you went low why'd you
do that because I want to avoid your
heart you mean you could stop my heart
from beating I don't know why okay we're
okay let me try it on you for a second
okay okay like that it seems to have no
effect on you you have to remember you
need to need to port make sure you talk
it's going again all right okay that's
incredible that's incredibly powerful
yeah you can get a lot of it you can get
a lot of power off that you can get a
lot of power out of one-inch sign on
that
now now
Phil is wrong
you know they encouraged me that's the
problem
it didn't work on me but maybe we'll try
it on the board okay it's on the board
what is this oh okay okay so we're gonna
do the same actually when I was in South
Korea they taught me this so I did work
on this a little bit so one inch or just
make sure if you hit it incorrectly you
in a break a finger so be aware of that
okay how's that here remember our
breathing that we've done we did a few
years ago yeah inhale exhale and on the
exhale power through
[Applause]
we're killing the Bruce Lee Brown right
now
you